i'm sure at this point plenty of people  have heard about the great resignation  the thing that i'm way more worried  about as all of you go on your journey  to build the things that you want to  build is the great never applying in the  first place the amount of options 17 19  22 year olds have going into the world  and they're aware of it of how easy it  is to make sixty thousand dollars a year  flipping on ebay making content on tick  tock there are so many more options than  what we grew up with if you're over 35  here that it's profound you have to  understand what's coming up the ranks  these are 15 17 19 year olds that aren't  lazy that are not entitled that are not  soft they have options this is not about  they don't want to work this is about  i'm 16 and i make 250 000 a year on  youtube ads sorry mom i don't want to go  work at some [ __ ] place this is not  they're soft this is they're smart  [Music]